welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and spider-mans future looks
promising with an announced spin-off in
the works from past spider-man movie
screenwriter roberto orci it's gonna be
beyond the MCU spider-man 3 hopefully
still coming next summer Tom Holland
could keep his mouth shut about it's
insane lot and not infect us with
spoilers when you look at where C's past
work with these characters and combine
that with where Marvel and Sony are
likely to go for the upcoming spider-man
3 this news actually gives us a pretty
good indication of what this spin-off
could be how connected to the MCU it'll
be and whether it'll just pull a Morbius
and paint the movie storyboards as
graffiti in the background behind Jared
Leto so to understand why that's or see
spin-off news is important we got to
rewind the clock all the way back to
this was before our Lord and Savior Tom
Holland was birthed as Peter Parker in
the MCU so all the MCU expanding to new
levels of greatness with Captain America
Winter Soldier and guardians of the
galaxy even today both of those movies
feel so recent and essential but that
same summer Sony attempted to launch
their own separate spider-verse with the
amazing spider-man 2 a movie that feels
kind of like a forgotten past of all
live-action movies with spider-man in
the title it made the least money it got
the worst reviews and it's so freaked
out Sony that they decided to just hand
over the keys of the character to Marvel
movie starred Andrew Garfield as Peter
Parker Emma Stone as Gwen Stacy Jamie
Foxx's electro and Dane DeHaan as Harry
Osborn Green Goblin is directed by Marc
Webb with its screenplay by Jeff Pinker
Alex Kurtzman and Roberto Orci the guy
writing this next spin-off but back then
this trio had collaborated on a ton of
projects but it was this amazing
spider-man 2 that ended the partnership
Kurtzman wanted to continue with a third
Andrew Garfield Marc Webb spider-man
film while Orsi wanted to move on to
producing and directing other projects
if the amazing spider-man 2 had not
underperformed as much as it did and if
Sony hadn't been rattled by a
cyberattack months later the Sony
spider-verse would have been a very big
deal in our lives the amazing spider-man
2 ended with a tease of the arrival of
the sinister six Harry Osborn and his
associate Gustav fears plots to assemble
a band of criminals to take over New
York in the absence of spider-man who
was
a morning when Stacy for like eight
minutes this sinister six would have
been made up of Harry Osborn Green
Goblin Paul Giamatti as the Rhino who
breaks out of prison in the final scene
in battle spider-man as well as Doc Ock
vulture Mysterio in Kraven the hunter
brew Goddard was going to direct this
sinister six movie and it was originally
set for November 2016 Goddard planned
for it to be a redemption story that
might not even feature spider-man and
along with a third Andrew Garfield
amazing spider-man summer 2016
we also would have gotten venom a 2017
black cat movie written by West world
co-creator Lisa joy Nolan and also in
2017 a spider-man 2099 film but of
course Sony's partnership with Marvel
announced in 2015
dusted this hypothetical timeline from
existence all right of course
Sony held on to some of its spider-man
related projects venom and its upcoming
sequel with carnage and into the
spider-verse and its upcoming sequel but
what does all this mean for or see
spider-man spin-off which of those loose
thread stories is Sony used to lure him
back to the spider-man franchise look
folks when I'm holed up in this blue
dungeon it's hard to stay energized a
big help with me staying alert is bang
energy thanks to bang energy for
answering this video there are 20
different flavors of bang to choose from
they're all 16 ounce cans but this one
is their aikido coffee flavor heavenly
hazelnuts it's a 15 ounce can with 300
milligrams of caffeine and 20 grams of
protein yeah I can start my day now it's
a taste of morning it's the taste of
sunrise sunrise tastes like coffee if
you're a grown-up now that Suns being
shot up into the sky with a burner I got
bang on a histogram you can get 25% off
your order at bang - energy calm when
you use the code new rock stars 25 there
you can buy cans and bang energy
including their sweet tea their Kido
coffee flavors rainbow unicorn cotton
candy they got it all can also get
clothing fitness supplements all kinds
of stuff to be your best bang himself
thanks again to bang energy for
sponsoring this video thank you for that
get 25% off at bang - energy commies in
the code new rock stars 25 and followed
the inventor of bang on instagram at
bang energy dot CEO so roberto orci
spider-man spin-off will likely be a
story that both connects to and
complements the upcoming Tom Holland MCU
spider-man 3 our assumption for that
third film is that that movie will be a
sinister six movie based on how many
villains homecoming
apart from home have established
potentially left alive and appear to be
meeting each other in other Sony films
but based on the little we know about
the MCU spider-man 3 it doesn't
necessarily have to be a full sinister
six story far from home ended with Peter
Parker outed and accused as a criminal
by Jay jonah jameson meanwhile director
john watson tom holland have hinted that
the villain could be Kraven the hunter
set photos on other Sony films have
shown Kraven catering trucks and Kraven
would be the perfect villain to lead a
manhunt for Peter Parker on behalf a Jay
jonah Jameson perhaps an adaptation of
Cravens last hunt Tom Holland has also
recently said that the movies script is
quote insane and we broke down what that
can mean in our recent quarantine
approved episode of rogue theory and
rumors are swirling that Matt Murdock
daredevil could join the film as part of
Peter Parker's legal defense so a
spider-man Kraven Jay jonah Jameson
story is already a delicious burrito
bowl of a movie concept adding another
iconic Marvel character like daredevil
it's kind of like an extra scoop and
walk and I'm not gonna complain about
but then also adding the full sinister
six that's an additional burrito
I will also eat it but I will not savor
each ingredient as much as I will just
like because they will eat every day in
front of me
it's also worth noting that despite Sony
shelving its 2014 era spider-verse plan
in the years since the studio still
gradually has been building something
close to that original plan vulture and
homecoming Mysterio and far from home
maybe Kraven in the third film
spider-man 2029 in the post-credits
scene of into the spider-verse Sony
didn't shelve its spider-verse plan it
just went through Marvel and animation
to watch versions of these characters
that fans really love and want to see
more of so when it comes to this or see
spider-man spin-off a separate sinister
six movie tops a list perhaps the 2014
Don Giovanni sinister six didn't seem
too exciting but hey a Keaton Gyllenhaal
sinister six don't knock my mama and
spider-man three could end with Kraven
driving Peter Parker out of the picture
setting the stage for a sinister six
story without Peter but who would be the
hero of that story well I think Tom
Hollands spider-man 3 will also
introduce a new spider-man that Sony can
exert greater control over in future
spider-man movies post Tom Holland so
I'm thinking we will meet a live action
Miles Morales and/or Gwen Stacy my
Morales has been confirmed to exist in
this movie universe with Donald Glover
playing Aaron Davis in homecoming and
mentioning a nephew
I don't want those weapons in his
neighborhood I got a nephew who live
here yes sorry miles I'm not gonna make
it and some thought they'd spotted Gwen
Stacy and Peter's high school and
Avengers in game but that was just an
extra who gets web pattern skirts at Hot
Topic but maybe part of the reason or
see parted ways with the amazing
spider-man franchise was an interest in
Gwen Stacy as a character beyond the
death of when Stacy's storyline that the
amazing spider-man 2 kind of rushed into
that movie but whatever this spin-off
film is it will likely be semi connected
to the MCU but not so much that Sony
would have to co-produce it with marble
unless the next three years go the way I
have predicted them to and Disney just
buys out all of Sony the way they did
for Fox and we no longer have to debate
what is and it's not MCU canon because
everything is reminder that new
rockstars is spending this social
distancing period with a rewatch of
Marvel's infinity saga starting with
Peter Parker surrogate daddy iron man
video coming up soon followed by another
semi canonical overlooked Marvel film
The Incredible Hulk yes it happened and
it was actually pretty great watch along
with me every Friday on our discord
server by becoming a patron of new
rockstars at patreon.com slash new
rockstars comment down below with what
you want the spider-man spin-off film to
be follow me at eat a vos follow new
rockstars and subscribed into rockstars
here on YouTube for breakdowns for
everything Marvel thanks for watching
bye
[Music]